[Music]
foreign
stuart friedman great to have you here
good to be here michael
where are you talking from now you're
home yes i'm uh
talking to you from uh redwood city
redwood city wonderful i mean i'm in
southern california so i'm a
i'm a also spending quarantine here at
home how has it been working for you
from home for the past
three or four weeks
whether it be home or every starbucks
from
here into the other side of the world uh
for the past 15 years and so
or out of my clients offices so being
out on my own is uh
is is nothing new all right so maybe
let's just start give maybe a tip or two
to people that
are now having to struggle to work from
home
in an environment that has a lot of
distraction and you know it's it's not
it's not
easy to just sit in the living room and
and try to get some work done
right you know it's it's really
fascinating one of the things that i've
i've found in the 15 years or so that
i've been doing this is
there are so many aspects of trust
um alignment and miscommunication
that just about every company on the
planet has
regardless of their makeup um and those
things are only exasperate the
disaster sorry
uh i've only gotten worse
due to the pandemic and uh
let's hope mispronunciating a word is
not an early symptom
to coronavirus it has that's you know
the news has been saying a lot of things
it hasn't said yet this yet
right but um there is so much that
is uh outside of our normal
considerations and how to interact with
people
even when we've had a wide bandwidth
communication channels
in other words meeting with people but
now
we really lose all that subtlety and
nuance nonverbal
and so if there have been problems in
the past with miscommunications or
building trust
they're uh just going to get a lot worse
now and so people need to be aware of
these things and
very much on top of them okay so you're
already talking about
trust and communication methods and and
so
you're a culture expert right that's how
i got to know you
over uh about five six years ago what is
talk to me a little bit about what what
is what does it mean to be sort of a
culture
expert and to understand how different
cultures communicate work together
respect each other
etc you know it's interesting because i
i as you mentioned i started talking
trust and you're back to culture
it's amazing how many companies will say
to me
uh thanks but we don't have any cultural
issues here
uh i hear that more times than than you
believe in fact i
i hear that a lot from uh israeli
companies that are based in the us
and i'll give you a great uh israeli
company story
i was introduced to a ceo here
domestically
of an israeli management team although
the company's based here in the us
and i was advi i met with the ceo on the
recommendation of a former
colleague and client saying that the ceo
had a very high turnover in his company
and maybe i could help him
work through that so i met with the ceo
and after i felt like we built a pretty
good dialogue
i said uh and by the way it's it's all
together possible that
part of the conflict that your employees
are experiencing
are um the way you address issues with
them and the way you
uh bring up confrontations and
uh the style of the discussion to which
the ceo said to me
uh stuart that's uh that's simply not
true
i've been in the country for 25 years
and as far as i can tell
i'm no different than all the other ceos
only that's not the way he said it to me
the way he said it to me was
stewart what are you talking about i'm
the same as every other ceo
that you've ever met and the same and so
he was in fact fairly oblivious
to his own communication style this is
true of all of us we all have blind
spots and and so
let me tie now the mistrust and the
um uh miscommunications back to culture
you know michael as you and i talked
about when we first met
the problem with the golden rule
treating other people the way we want to
be treated
is that that whole rule really was
defined
across the world religions thousands of
years ago
but in a time when people didn't travel
more than 30 miles in their entire
lifespan
yes so there was very little if any
opportunity
to come across a group of people whose
underlying values beliefs and
assumptions
were very different than their own the
golden rule breaks
when the person who i would like to
treat the way
i would like to be who i'm going to
treat the way i'd like to be treated
actually has different expectations on
how they want to be treated
and uh that happens again of course all
cultures based on
their sense of community their sense of
individualism
the sense on how they uh how important
saving faces to them things of that sort
right no i mean that makes perfect sense
and so so give me give me a few examples
on
on where do you see some of these
cultural differences
are there any specific specific things
that we can take into account
yeah absolutely uh and uh you know one
of the
interesting things about someone's
experience is
no matter how much you've had experience
or accomplishment success you've had
when you're dealing with another culture
you can't just extrapolate out i'll give
you a good
good story i have this one client
here in silicon valley large
semiconductor company
who had a customer in sweden that they
had been having
lots of trust and miscommunications with
yeah
and uh so the director of engineering
for the swedish
uh customer came over here to meet with
my client
and my client wanted to take them out
for a very nice dinner
uh show their appreciation for the
business and so
they said to the director of engineering
from the swedish customer
uh we know in sweden you eat a lot of
seafood
uh how about sushi do you like sushi and
the uh the gentleman from sweden said oh
yeah sure i love
sushi so they said great if you don't
mind the drive
we'll go up to san francisco we know of
a really great place
some of the best sushi we've ever had
the swedish guy said sure
so they sit in bay area rush traffic
coming from where they were maybe took
90 minutes to get up there they sit down
and they go to order and what is their
swedish customer
director of engineering who apparently
has had some global experience
what does he do he orders chicken
teriyaki
so my clients telling me the story you
see how difficult it is to deal with
this guy
can you imagine if he's ordering chicken
teriyaki when we made special plans
to go to the best sushi place can you
imagine how difficult he must be
in a normal uh business relationship
well right away i had some indication so
i
contacted that restaurant and uh i got a
chance to look at their menu
and what i noticed was something that
brought first and
upfront to my mind was a swedish
let's just say it's part of their
national psyche it's something called
lagum
l-a-g-o-m and london
is in a sense the driving force behind
the children's story
goldilocks and the three bears it's not
too hot not too cold
logan is everything in moderation we
don't want to go to an extreme
so when looking at the menu what i saw
was for dinner a large sushi combo
and a small sushi combo
but there was no average sushi combo
so the swedish director of engineering
went through the following mental
process unbeknownst
to his host if he orders the large sushi
complex
that's so our sushi combo
it'll seem like he's taking advantage of
his
host if he orders a small one
it will seem like he's not being
appreciative enough
so we ordered the chicken teriyaki
because it just seemed like the easier
solution
right so here's a great example of
now let's transpose that into a business
situation imagine that my client
had gone out numerous times trying to
get this customer interested in
some extreme new technology or feature
or functionality that was one of a kind
and out on the extreme
edges of performance would that excite
the swedish no we he wants something in
mainstream something solid something
he can count on something reliable and
so that's just
one indication in sweden where this
notion of
uh finding a middle ground can manifest
itself
in not just our uh personal lives but in
business
right right wow okay so
so what actually do you do with with
these companies that you come and help
them
so obviously you can come and and try to
investigate
certain and extrapolate on certain
situations but
how does this impact on a larger scale i
mean at the end you know i'm thinking of
of a company that i want to build later
on in my life and i know okay yes i'm
going to have
an r d team in tel aviv and i'll
probably have one in ukraine as well and
i might want to have some marketing
and some finance in dublin and some and
some
you know work in china how do i how do i
as a ceo
can either use your resources or get
these resources myself
so i think the first thing to understand
as a michael the first thing to
understand as a ceo
is to recognize your own
uh biases your own beliefs
your own limiting views on any situation
because once you have
a handle that uh that you have a
specific set of underlying assumptions
about the way of interacting with other
people the easier it will be to
understand
the plethora of other values and beliefs
that other people have
right and once you've done that you can
then make an assessment
of whether those uh reasons to rely on
ireland or the us
or eastern europe or wherever
uh if you can bake into your plan
to make sure that you and your team are
properly educated
as to how those people uh
uh get work done in fact if you think
about it that's
really the definition of culture but how
things get done around here yeah
okay so i i i guess i i could go and do
this research and even my leadership
team
will be fine but now i'm now the company
is a thousand people
and i have hundreds of people in every
location that and we're working
constantly on the same products
okay is it reasonable to to try and to
teach
you know a hundred employees in tel aviv
how the employees in dublin
are expecting them to communicate
absolutely it is
and and let's not let's not forget that
while there are certain underlying
governing if you will at times
dynamics and values that are indicative
of a culture let's not make the mistake
of throwing out individuality
because at the end of the day we're all
individuals yeah
in one way or another we have similar
we've often heard said we have as
a species we have more similarities than
we have differences sure
that's certainly true on a
country-by-country basis
so the point being is that the way
people behave in a certain culture
is to a certain extent reliable uh
repeatable and predictable right so yes
you can put a program together for a
hundred
five hundred thousand people you get
them all on the same page
to understand how to transpose
or modify the way they communicate in
one country
or with one group of people to another
yes absolutely i do that all the time
so so how how intensive is this
participation of yours within a company
is this more of an advisory role
or is it an is it a long-term engagement
with a company where you have to really
understand their culture
well i've done everything from if you
will cultural triage
and sometimes after the fact where all
of a sudden
the you know what's hit the fan and so
now they want me to come in and try to
make all good and the problems with
trust is
in many cases if i come in too late i
can identify what went wrong but
you know it's sure it's better to just
get in up front right
yep uh so uh
so so the best thing in uh in the world
is to uh
be able to get everybody in that
organization
to understand again as individuals and
as a team
what their priorities are in terms of
how they value when they believe things
and then understand how that differs
from and back to your question
are they dealing with one country are
they dealing with 10 countries
are they dealing with uh different
functional
organizations um all of these things can
either simplify the engagement
or can make the engagement uh quite
involved i've done everything from these
triages
where i go in after the fact to half day
executive one-on-ones to uh week-long
uh trainings that include an entire
range of countries
and business processes how do they
negotiate one culture versus another
sure the other thing i want to add to
the mix here michael
is so many people
give a presentation in one country as
they give it in the other and the next
and the next right
now ever changing their slides but what
we know about cultural value differences
is that one country might want a
presentation that's much heavier on
data and facts while another might want
presentation heavier on context and
relationships and
previous experiences so i may have
somebody who says
i don't really care about negotiating in
the selling process
but i want to give the same level of
presentation
uh performance in one country as i do in
all other countries
yeah so now we're in this in the
craziest of times corona times and this
is more relevant than ever right i mean
teams are distributed and are
if even if before we would have more of
a formal setting even
at a workplace where we would meet and
be able to engage with each other and
read each other's body languages now
it's it's becoming much harder
how much more difficult is it to to sort
of engage in these cultural differences
you know over
slack or email than it is in person and
and
so and how are you seeing this
transition happening now with with the
coronavirus
yeah so you know it's um
i was just reading a new book by uh uh
bill davidow the former uh the vc and
former vp of marketing intel
uh his book is called the autonomous
revolution and in it
he talks about a scientific concept
uh called phase shift where
the chemical or material properties may
remain the same but something happens to
change the game
and change the game in way that you
can't any longer take what you used to
do before and apply it to a new
situation
and the example he gives of course is
everything we understand we know about
water
tells us nothing about how to deal with
ice
everything we understand about
communicating across cultures
in a broad bandwidth channel meaning
face to face
communicating socially getting together
both inside the work environment as well
as after hours
cannot be extrapolated out how people
are going to communicate
solely on emails and on web conferences
we are going to miss
so much of that communications you know
there are some
cultures in the world where any of the
real candor
any of the real sensitivity doesn't ever
get discussed
in the meeting room it gets discussed
one-on-one in person
or after hours in the social engagement
so it's really important to recognize
uh first that we're dealing with an
entirely different situation
second there's a fundamental dynamic of
culture which is really troubling in a
time like this
and that is the more stress and pressure
that somebody
is feeling the more apt they are
regardless of what they've learned to
resort back
to their own primal cultural values
and so getting them to be able to
balance today's anxiety
and today's stress with still keeping if
you will
a third eye open to cultural differences
this isn't something that's gonna could
happen easily
yeah no that makes perfect sense so what
is one advice you would give
to every you know to every company in
the world right now
as we're as we're prepping for what
could potentially be you know a
year-long engagement that's all virtual
sure whatever you may have thought about
cultural differences in the past
the question becomes the following
has there ever been a relationship that
you've had with somebody
where you trusted them more by an email
exchange
than you ever did by meeting them in
person or was there anybody that you've
ever trusted more
with a phone call or a web call than you
ever have
by meeting them in person and i think we
already know the answer is no
yeah we trust people more in person take
that away from us
and now one now ask yourself if they've
ever
been trust issues alignment issues
or miscommunications in the past how
you're going to manage those going
forward in a world where our bandwidth
of communication
is so so hindered and the answer is
really simple
it's through learning basic differences
in the way
people uh manage their time
prioritize delegate lead make decisions
and uh it's attainable it can be done
and
it can it can the great thing about this
is these changes don't take a long time
to implement or to see results uh
you can in as difficult as the times are
right now
uh you can ensure much greater success
uh by adhering to uh some of this
different values and beliefs
i think it's a it's fascinating the the
world that you live in and
in the global context and the and the
cultural
differences and you know i'm looking
forward to also trying to practice a lot
that understanding and knowledge
on my end later on and also now as i'm
engaging the various activities
and stuart before we leave i i need
three words that describe you
um passionately
uh humorous yes
and uh
uh insightful i like it
stuart thank you very very much stay
healthy stay safe
you too michael take care thanks again
bye